for those of you who have come to a lot
of my lecturers you know that I really
really love the fianchetto I really
enjoy putting my bishops on the long
diagonals g3 g6 b3 b6 and what this
stretch is what this lecture is going to
be about is what happens when you very
very clever genius that you are
fianchetto your bishop and your opponent
blocks the diagonal
okay blocks the diagonal with his pawns
what are you what are you going to do in
this particular game I was facing
Anthony miles
Anthony miles was a grandmaster from the
United Kingdom
and one of the top top players in the
world and what Tony had been doing with
the black pieces was playing a very very
early B 7 B 6 against efore b6 and a
very quick fianchetto against d4 b6
quick fianchetto against everything he
was playing b6 and in a competition in
bath the European team Championships the
UK team had played against the Soviet
Union and miles had defeated Anatoly
Karpov then the reigning world champion
with his quick Queen side fianchetto so
I didn't want to be but you know the
latest in a long long long line of
victims of Tony miles fianchetto so we
came to the game we shook hands the
arbiter said start your clocks gentlemen
and my opening move was g3
well Tony leaned across the board and he
said to me I love these moral victories
we both had a very good laugh in those
days I really liked to play the English
opening and after my first move g3 Tony
played five and like a shot
I played the English I knew if I had
opened with one c4 he would feed shadow
as Bishop so I had gotten him into a
position I wanted on the other hand I've
made a very early commitment to the move
g3 in other words if I had played the
standard move c4 and he had played the
standard response a5 I would have played
on move to Knight c3 and not g3 welcome
welcome welcome come on in hi guys
welcome welcome welcome
I played g3 he played c7 c6
I played Bishop g2 and he played d5 okay
I mean very reasonable idea occupy the
center as black I captured on d5 he
captured on d5 and I played the move d4
now what I'm trying to do is get an
isolated queen pawn I want him to play
the move pawn takes e5 pawn ePHI takes
d4 I should say I want to play the move
Knight f3 I want him to play knight c6 I
want to capture Knight f6 and for those
of you who are in the know we have
transposed into a position from the
tirage defense of the Queens gambit
declined a position I like for white
White's Bishop on g2
does a pretty nice job at targeting this
pawn on d5 this is what I wanted Tony
wasn't playing ball to the ball game I
wanted and he played the movie 5e for
which brings me to the heart of the
lecture of the strategic ideas class
okay so now we've got this Bishop on g2
and it's clearly biting on granite these
two pawns really limit the scope of our
Bishop oh man that sucks yeah and you
know like G what do we do now so one
thing we can do is give up we could like
move our pawn to e3 it kind of looks
like a French defense and then bring our
bishop back to its original square and
have a bad game yeah the other thing we
can do is break out we can we can fight
for a control of this pawn on e4 in
other words we can play the move f2 f3
okay so I'm attacking this pawn on e4 I
would be very grateful if black would be
so kind as to capture my pawn well in
that case first of all after I recapture
it means that black has lost a lot of
time he's advanced his pawn to e5 to e4
and then moved it a third time
so now I have a very large advantage in
development and I stand very well it
would be much better and it was in fact
what Tony did was to play the move f5
maintaining
as best he can this pawn on e4 okay now
in chess there's give-and-take you
always have to weigh the scales of what
you've of what move you've made if we go
back just one move we see that black
felt himself compelled to defend the
pawn on e4 and he did it with the move
f5
what's the drawback of f5 pardon me Ken
it weakens the black king side that is
certainly true other thoughts that was
the one I wanted this Bishop on c8 a
moment ago we put the pawn back on f7
this bishop had squares we put the pawn
on f5 we block the bishop on c8
this may not seem like anything major or
what have you
however it is important after f5 I play
the natural knight c3 I think he played
knight c6 I played knight h3 this is the
next part of this strategic ideas class
is we understand my bishop is really
kind of passive but certain things have
happened
by having provoked the move f5 this
bishop is no longer attacking my knight
this pawn starts to become the center of
my attention I want to bring my knight
to here if I could win this pawn if I
could just capture and remove this pawn
illegally just take the font off the
board say your turn
well my opponent would be very sad but
even worse it would mean that he
couldn't maintain his blockade on e4
let's see Tony play Knight here
Bishop g5 Bishop e7 castle Bishop here
night here Bishop here III so we got
this position okay I think he Castle
okay so castles okay
so now we got a position that looks very
much like a French defense for those of
you who are familiar with the French
defense it's like a French defense
reversed but White has significant
pluses over a normal French defense in
the first place and then the normal
French defense is black it's like this
bishop on c1 never never gets out to
this beautiful square over here never
happen so already that's a big plus in
this position I believe I have played
Bishop h3 so it's not it's sort of like
okay you've kind of denied me this
diagonal let me play Bishop h3 let me
make a new target I want to take this
pawn Tony has played g6
I have captured captured captured now
black has a problem he cannot capture
recapture with this pawn because there's
a fork down on the e6 square so pardon
me let me just put that on the board so
if he recaptures with this prawn check
sorry
Bishop 96 Bishop takes Bishop takes
check King over and his whole Center
just collapses my next move is to
capture second pawn and that was a good
deal he had to capture like this
new mainline and now I play g4 and
basically what happened is Tony's
position collapsed once he captured on
g4 I captured on g4 I came back with my
bishop and I won this pawn so that was
just an example of how to treat a
position where the bishop was kept in
let's do that again and let's do these
kinds of strategic positions occur all
the time you know very very large
numbers of variations let me show you
another one
efore c5 so white plays the clever move
Knight f3 and in White's mind you know
he wants to play an open Sicilian and
getcha okay
I play g6 and I say go ahead and play
your open Sicilian and white says well
if you're going to play g6 I'm going to
occupy the center why not I'll play C 3
after C 3 Bishop g7 d4 takes tanks and
doesn't this look familiar
d5 it's the same position the mirror
position reversed
I want yes except the knight is on a
three I want black pardon me I want
white to play II takes d5 so that I can
play Knight f6 recapture on d5 with the
knight play against the isolated pawn my
opponents play e5 so once more they're
trying to shut down my bishop on g7 now
in this particular case as opposed to
the case with Tony miles miles put his
paw
on f4 in this case the night is already
committed itself to f3
I play the move f6 yep okay let's just
say for argument's sake Knight c3 knight
c6 okay so we have a position like this
so my idea obviously is I want to put
pressure on this pawn at the moment
White has already countered by putting
pressure against this pawn on d5 but
okay if it's my turn my idea is I want
to play Bishop to g4 attacking this
knight that's protecting this pawn and
at every moment I'm trying to resolve
I'm trying to provoke I should say white
into capturing on f6 if white would
please please oblige me by attacking by
trading it's a big success because once
more white has played once twice three
times with a pawn we can see one two
three four five development four black
one two three three development moves
for white so white is already
significantly worse in this position
Julian what do you think white should
play
Queen b3 an excellent look I like this
move Queen b3 for several reasons the
first and foremost is white is putting
pressure on this pawn on e6 on d5 he's
also trying to prevent black from
developing the bishop on g4 which would
have been that nasty pin and this pawn
on d4 would be under attack so this move
Queen b3
is really aimed against this bishop
white is really attempting to keep this
bishops literally anchored to his pawn
that's point number one point number two
is white wants to win upon either Lear
at fate you're trying to win my phone he
plays a queen b3 attacking the pawn on
e6 regretfully and it's with deep
regrets that it truly is i play the
movie 7e six protecting my pawn but
sadly try I caused my Bishop to remain
passive however I take a little solace
in this movie six because a moment ago I
was not threatening to capture this pawn
twice when your Queen knows on d1
because my d5 square would have been a
defy pawn would have been under tack but
now I am so now White has to deal with
this threat usually white plays Bishop
f4 again I would welcome this trade this
is like welcome welcome welcome so white
usually tries to maintain his this pawn
he can maintain the pawn in a different
way Bishop b5 but it's not a hundred
percent that you ever really want to
part with this Bishop for this night
would you agree that Bishop f4 is is a
moon okay so Bishop f4 now oops sorry
yeah now in a different world on a
different planet if my King was really
really safe I could be a genius and take
this pawn Knight takes Knight takes pawn
takes and very cleverly when I collapse
white Center the problem is I don't I
don't really I don't want to open the
position whilst my King is still in the
center okay so in this position I'm
going to take on e5 and I presume you
want to take with the pawn yeah okay so
take stakes now here this is a very key
moment for black remember or recall
rather that in my game with Tony miles I
put my night here on h6 or it actually
was h3 so that I could come to f5 there
is a lot to be said for Knight h6 to
come to f7 to attack this pawn on e5
also from blacks point of view black
could be thinking well as soon as I can
so quickly with my king and rook I'm
going to gain a tempo against the bishop
and that's very very useful so while
it's an awkward decision Knight h6 or 97
I'm just going to go with 97 just to
demonstrate and in fact I already have
demonstrated that when your opponent's
try to lock in your Bishop don't let
them play
f7 f6 and turn the tables basically with
this move Knight a 7
what black is trying to say is I want to
win this pong okay
so I move for white Bishop e2 Bishop d3
Bishop d3 excellent okay and again for
those of you who are familiar with
Sicilians and French defense situations
you should know that these types of
exchange sacrifices are extremely
typical and happened all the time and I
would win a lot of games with these
types of exchange sacrifices after rook
takes f3 pawn takes f3 Knight takes e5
in the first place I already have a pawn
for the exchange in the second place and
I always love this is my opponent's king
is vulnerable whether whether white
decides that he wants to put his king
over here or over here he won't find
safety and on my side of the board after
a move like Knight f5 my King is
extraordinarily safe and I've got ideas
like Knight d4 for King Queen Bishop in
short things have gone seriously
seriously wrong let's go back back back
and let's see another situation this
should also be rather typical for your
cells d4 in variation b6 let's say c4
let's say e 6 let's say e for let's say
Bishop DISA okay this is a very very
standard opening ah we can almost call
it the Tony Myles defense because Tony
Myles embraced it so very often when he
was black okay
there's a real real sharp variation but
basically when you look at games from
this defense the one overwhelming thing
that comes in time and time and time
again is black is constantly fighting to
keep this diagonal open let's say white
plays the move Bishop d3 this is the
move order I want it so in this position
we see that while white hasn't yet
played the move d5 which firmly kills
your Bishop white didn't want to play
this move too early because after the
move d5 maybe this night would come to
the square c5 so white first plays
Bishop d3 with the idea in the long term
he's going to kill the bishop with d5
black would play the move f5 okay Wow
he takes f5 this just absolutely looks
killing so with this movie takes F 5
it's absolutely clear that if black
tries to win a rook with Bishop takes G
to Queen h5 check woo blacks king is in
real trouble
King even simply cost the bishop black
and resign and the move g7 g6
looks absolutely devastating because of
pawn takes right so this looks
absolutely tragic no uh right so White's
threat his g7 so so hold on in case of
Knight f6 black attacks whites Queen
White has this beautiful little tactic
g7 Czech Knight takes Queen and he gets
the clean back by capturing the rook and
black and resign so in this position it
looks like black is busted in
devastating but the move here is Bishop
g7 pawn takes h7 check King f8 now this
is an absolutely wild position and the
idea from blacks point of view is in
case you take this night with check King
takes Queen here Bishop takes blacks and
exchange up it's like one of those
things isn't this amazing almost from
the very start you put his bishop on the
long diagonal and check this out he was
rewarded with the move with the win of a
rook exactly
amazing amazing well there was a game a
fantastic game grandmaster Walter brown
was white Tony miles was black and Grand
Master Walter Brown came up with an
incredible idea a devastating idea and a
very very difficult one to see I haven't
checked it with the latest chess engines
but remarkably Walter brown did not
capture this night instead Walter played
a rook behind
he played Bishop g5 Knight f6 Queen h4
and said your turn
Tony took a rook Walter played Knight
here Knight came to c6 I believe and
either Walter played this move Knight f3
or he played this move I can't be sure
what it was so now even though Walters a
rook behind what Walters idea was that
he has threats of Knight g6 check
he has threats of Knight h5 and Knight
takes g7 also he wants to play Knight c3
castle
when a tempo against the bishop and one
day play for the potential of 94 it was
an amazing amazing tussle and white one
but I don't want that to ruin our
pleasure of this idea of the strategic
class and this this desire to play f5
what happened here is instead of playing
f5 a lot of black players included the
move Bishop d3 check Bishop b4 check
new mainline Knight c3 and here they
played the move f5 so the difference is
that now when you capture this pawn
Bishop captures g2 Queen goes to h5
you're not compelled to play the move g6
but instead you can play the move King
f8
okay so recommendations for white what
do you think white should do now
f3 defending the pawn okay well this is
one of the things this is a like a
typical tactic that occurs time and time
again and I I remember falling for this
kind of tactic as well as playing the
tactic itself it basically has to do
with the fact that whenever Black has
played the move f5 or widest played the
move f3 you open up your king to the
vulnerability of a potential check so
here you go
takes takes takes takes takes okay so
this is black's big idea that after
Bishop takes e4 he'll meet that with a
check and I think we've all fallen for
this a time or two in our lives yes
queen h5 check correct yes
so yeah queen h5 check so queen ePHI
exactly exactly this is so this is what
makes chests so cool new variation so
just to repeat myself
pardon me Bishop takes e4 this ship
takes e4 black is really happy he's
about to win the game white now tries to
turn the tables with wait a minute
before you get a chance to check me I
want to check you
so queen h5 check and in case of the
move g6 Queen e5 and look at this a
moment ago white lost his rook on h1
seconds later black is losing his rook
on h8
what would sorry what is the best
continuation yes Queen takes H queen
tanks h8 right Queen takes h8 look looks
just winning King at 7 check and correct
that's exactly right you should play
Bishop takes d3 but even so in this
position
White has won an exchange and it strikes
me that correct that black king is the
one that's in trouble
these fianchetto lines ok let's say
Bishop d3 Bishop b4 check one of the
things that I like to do here when I was
white is surprise surprise I like to
play the move King f1 ok it looks
strange and it is but there's a very
concrete reason behind this move King f1
that was that in some variations I'm not
going after this bishop by trying to
play d5 I'm going after this bishop by
trying to play c5 takes an a3 to trap
that Bishop and I would have a lot of
fun with these games too by the way they
were exactly and I stopped this f5
business okay so now f5 simply runs into
captures there's no Bishop takes g2 and
ideas but these lines and that was
really what I wanted to emphasize
let's say in this position is if white
tries to shut down this bishop so before
I had a kingside fianchetto now there's
a queen side fianchetto and white tries
to shut down this bishop with a move
like d5 don't go forever don't let your
bishop get shut down
first of all play for levers like f5 you
want to also in this in this case you're
not so incredibly upset that this bishop
is shut down you think that in the
future you'll play a move like c6 what
this move has done d5 is opened up a
beautiful outpost for this night so what
you would want to do with you if you
were black here is you wouldn't want to
play a move like Knight a six so that
just for argument's sake if Knight c3
Bishop b4 if Knight f3 let's say the
knight could come to a sick at night on
a six could come to c5 it's a beautiful
outpost for the night
in other words White has played the move
d5 to try to arrest your Bishop but as a
consequence he's given your knight a
beautiful outpost on the c5 square so
this fight between center control versus
of thean shadow Bishop and when is a
blockaded Bishop good or bad always
depends upon whether or not you can
fight your way out you can clear the
diagonal I urge you to look at some of
the games of Grandmaster Alexander
Shibboleth Tony miles and others for
Queen side fianchetto z-- where I've
seen lines were black with a white
was compelled to capture this pawn black
we captured his Bishop was beautiful his
rook was Castle then he Shabalala
and Tony have won some really beautiful
games with this fianchetto device